since there may be some people online
I'll I'll sort of start or tell you what
we're planning to do um which isn't much
so um the the reason we're here this
morning is to act on house Bill 436
which was the you know a major change to
the retirement plan of group two uh an
enhancement um for for certain um uh
certain members and uh that has been
delayed you know the house put put it
into House Bill 2 it um was taken out by
the Senate so it's not in the final
version of the budget in any way and so
the bill but the bill itself was
retained by our committee and it's still
here and we're going to be executing it
later today in the big room so the
question is what are we going to do okay
and now we have a quorum
so just slightly giving a little
background that we have to act on House
Bill 436 because it was retained and and
the original plan was to wait for the
there was a commission dealing with this
issue um and to wait for their
recommendation and then use this bill as
a vehicle for that issue um but as I
understand it that's not ready and so we
may have another plan
so so good morning sorry I'm a little
late um
so there's been a lot of uh perhaps
drama in the whole issue we were hoping
as Dan or representative Maguire said to
have something uh ready to present the
uh commission voted 8
to6 last Thursday to support a
plan however trying to get the uh LBA
and again not to throw anyone under the
bus because it was just way too short a
time to get things together together uh
the retirement system Marty's been great
trying to get some of the factual
numbers the financial impact both on the
state and the municipalities together
which uh obviously takes some time so
the plan going
forward is that uh and I have to give
representative eil some credit for
putting this bug in my ear yesterday um
I was thinking that we could go to the
rules committee once we get everything
done for a late introduction of a a bill
to address what 436 did and some other
additions that the U retirement
commission
suggested and Karen said well gee I
think the rules committee I'm sorry
representative
evil said the rules committee some time
ago said if a commission and I'm sure
all of you already know this anyway but
I had forgotten but if a commission
makes a recommendation you can file a
late introduction so that's what we're
going going to do going to get all the
facts together allow the retirement
system and the LBA and Os to get
everything lined up as I think all of
you sitting out here know that the
division takes a lot of pride in their
work we want all the numbers we're not
going to just push something forward
without the facts especially the
financial facts which we'll have in a
couple of
weeks uh in the meantime I guess we'll
act on the bill before us uh we can
either retain it not retain but interim
study or itl it I know Dan had had some
amendments that he would had talked
about at one point if we brought this
forward but again the process going
forward uh somebody will introduce the
new legislation um I there'll be a
hearing a public hearing it'll go to
Edna first they'll have a at least one
or two public hearings on it then if it
is successful getting out of there on
the floor of the house it will come here
there'll be an expedited process at
least in the house we'll try to push it
forward the speaker wants everyone to
know he's completely behind getting this
issue behind us once and for all and
supports what we're suggesting here and
at that unless representa maggu has
something else to add or anybody else
thank you thank you Mr chairman so first
of all I'd like to uh just say that the
what the retirement commission ended up
doing as as I understand it has two
particular features one is that it's
just a change of the multiplier from two
to 2 and a
half% um and that it applies to all
group two current employees not just
this particular group and it just
happens that that's exactly what I was
arguing for or six months ago when I got
shouted down
so um so I'm in favor of
it and um but uh the one thing that's
that's so the choices for House Bill 436
are simply itl and wait for this bill um
but we we do have a prepared Amendment
which if you remember house bill 50 was
the bill that I convinced you to um to
pay down the unfunded liability with $50
million right and that would um that
would get us a little bit less in debt a
little quicker um and it the also
consequence of that would be um
employers would pay a little bit less
towards the unfunded liability in the
future and so we that that we passed as
the house very fairly strongly we tabled
it and we put it in House Bill two and
the Senate ripped it out so um so we
have an amendment today if we wanted to
you know bring up that issue again and
push it forward we could make House Bill
436 into house bill 50 and and send it
forward that way it's it's just a
possibility I I don't know that it's
worth doing or whatever but
anyway so would you like to offer that
amendment I assuming uh Melissa has it
yes represent cells yes thank you Mr
chair just a point of clarification um
if if they proceed with the plan that
you discussed it would be a totally new
bill and 436 has nothing to do with it
that's correct yeah thank
you
present Maguire
thank you
so I want to point out that um this 50
million is slightly different than um if
in the bill we've been talking about the
one for group two you simply raised the
amount by 50 million right because
because the retirement system separately
tracks the unfunded liability for the
different categories right there's an
unfunded liability for teachers and for
other employees and for police and for
fire as I understand it and so um this
is 50 million across the board sort of
for everyone but but in the bill we've
been talking about which is strictly for
group two that if we added 50 million to
that it would strictly change the
unfunded liability for police and fire
right so it's there's a slight
difference I mean it's it's
probably somewhat inconsequential in
that you know most
well not exactly right because this
would change the rates a little bit for
schools for example and that wouldn't
right so um but in any case I guess I
will offer this I I'm in favor of it I
think we have the money sitting around
in the education trust fund doing
nothing and
so um so I I would like to pass this
is there a second to representative
Maguire's amendment number
2458 H well for discussion I'll second
it discussion on the
amendment represent cells anything yes
thank you Mr chair so basically
um it's a fiscally responsible thing to
do probably right to we have the money
it's Surplus money we'd be using
and we'd be bringing down the liability
which in in turn would lower the rates
going forward it uh it would help us to
take get reduce our debt in the state
could I respond sure thank you yes
so the way it works is if you put in a
dollar into the unfunded liability today
you don't have to put in a do
6.75 next year right and and A113 the
year after and so on right and um and so
it's effectively paying down a debt that
is accumulating at
6.75% and that as I understand it is the
highest rate of debt of any of our you
know it's more than State bonds and so
on so to me getting
6.75% is a reasonable thing to
do and um if we do end up going with the
other plan with the commission this all
goes away it it would not or would this
amendment go on to you said uh house
bill 50 it
would so this would be a completely this
is not this would be a separate bill
it's basically saying to the Senate we
want to re we want to you know you took
this out of the budget we didn't have a
committee of conference this is
something we want to argue for right but
it's separate from the other
thing yeah
further questions for representative
Maguire Marty would you like to comment
at all I KN you traveled all the way
over here might like to say
something thanks Mr chair I was hoping
to blend into the wallpaper today but um
didn't think that was likely um just
just the only comment is I just looked
on my phone at the fiscal note for the
house version of hp50 and saw that
that's that's where you would look for
the fiscal note to see the rate
reduction I think it's between
0.9% of pay for employees up to 0.21% of
pay for um fire and then the range in
between so so basically it would it
would reduce the unfunded portion of the
employer contribution rates not just in
the next rate cycle but going forward
and you know and so it this would be
akin to you know if you had uh you know
a significant credit card debt and you
put extra money on next month it's just
less that you're going to be paying an
interest over over time so again we
would not have any position on this bill
is from you know it's a policy decision
for the legislature and a fiscal
decision but just want to come up and
say all
that thanks Marty any questions for
Marty seeing none thanks thanks
all right seeing no further questions uh
I will comment that I will support
representative Maguire's
Amendment uh I think a lot of work was
done back uh prior to the budget it made
a lot of sense I think Marty's comments
add to that makes a lot of sense and
along with what representative McGuire's
already stated and when the clerk is
ready we'll have a
vote where everybody is today but make
sure who's here who
okay uh this is a vote on Amendment 2023
2458 offered by representative Maguire
and seconded by rep chair leean um so um
representative Maguire
yes representative
camell yes representative huitt
yes
um
so uh I'm just going to comment I in
light of everything that we have ahead
of us with respect to the retirement uh
funding um I will be respectfully voting
nay and it's not because I think paying
down the unfunded liability is a bad
idea um thank you so the clerk votes nay
so the is that every oh chair
leean yes okay so it's 4 to
one um and the amendment to uh HB 436
passes I move to pass with am okay I'll
move I'll move to pass with
Amendment and I'll
second okay probably no need for an
additional vote just okay um although I
was in favor say no okay
I
okay all right
okay the vote being 4 to1 the Maguire
Amendment passes and will be taken up by
the full committee at 10
a.m. as long as Marty's here could I ask
abely so I I sent Marty a few questions
about what the retirement commission did
um I should say Mr Carlo and
um a and so I wanted to to sort of
clarify um when you say he he responded
that so the the way the retirement
commission apparently wrote their bill
was that it was giving 50 million now um
but that there would be some cost to to
municipalities and others uh later on
well if is that right if I could be for
Marty response they actually didn't
write anything they had a concept that
they voted on yeah
so that's what made it a little more
difficult there was never any written
language it was like what this might do
the possible impact financially on
municipalities on the state but there
was never any draft I got it okay and
since the commission has not written
their final report there's nothing
really go on there so it was a vote on
the concept and that's what's made it a
little
more difficult to get our hands around
it so Marty presented to us
um different concepts that had been
batted back and forth and there were
some numbers that they were fairly
comfortable with the retirement but
nothing had really been firmed up I see
so but here's my question so when I
asked about that he said to me that um
if you put in 56 million
now then that pays for the change in
unfunded liability for this increase in
benefit but it doesn't pay for the
normal cost of the increase in benefit
in the future and what I wanted to make
sure is that I understand what that
means all right so is
the if you put in 56 million now that
pays
for um all of today's employees anybody
who's now working and how much they're
retirement is expected to be but it
doesn't pay for the guy hired next year
and who's getting a better benefit than
he would otherwise is that right yes um
just just to kind of build out on the on
the yes a little bit so so there there
are two pieces to um you know that go
well besides the medical subsidy there's
two pension pieces that go into funding
the unfunded liability which is being
paid off over a period of time and the
normal cost that representative Maguire
referred to and that's the cost of
benefits as they're acred that's what
the actuary says based on all the
Provisions in the statute um the
employer needs to put in x amount
percent of my pay to fund my benefit
when I retire or some Melissa's benefit
or or another any Public Employee so so
that's the normal cost um this proposal
by the uh commission and and the
commission by mutual agreement of the
Senate President and the speaker who
were both on the commission agreed to uh
authorize funding for us to reach out to
our actuary to sort of
um cost out some of these Concepts so um
th this particular proposal because it
affects um current and future group two
members so people who haven't been hired
yet but you know will be hired you know
tomorrow or 10 years from now you could
you
can't accurately capture the full
funding of that because you don't know
what inflation and demographics and
everything else are going to be in the
2030s and 2040s so the 55.9 million was
the unfunded liability portion of this
change that's basically the backfill you
know anybody who's affected by this
their multiplier in some cases is
retroactively larger if they had more
than 10 years based on you know when
they hit their anniversary so this
there's the um there's that liability
piece and what would if the um ultimate
legislative proposal funds that unfunded
piece there is a normal cost piece
associated with the future ongoing cost
of of this change you know for for
members you know current members and
members as they're hired in the future
um I I think one of your questions uh
representative Maguire was you know if
you paid more than 55 million could you
offset some of the future costs and the
answer is yes I'm not sure if an actuary
could say if you give us 65 it'll even
it out for the first five I don't you
know but it's like it's the same
Principle as your house bill 50
Amendment though it's like if you the
more you put on the unfunded it's just
less interest on your credit card you're
paying later May so spec let's talk
about a specific example which would
help me um suppose there's an employee
who's currently working has 15 years in
yeah and will retire 10 years from now
okay yeah so so there's an extra benefit
for the 15 years already but there will
also be an EXT benefit for the coming 10
years right so does the 56 million pay
for all of that for this particular
employee or is the next 10 years
part part of the normal cost that's not
being paid by the that's all the the
backfilling you know so if you had so 15
15E employee just so they would have
started in 2008 so they would have hit
their 10th anniversary in
2018 um I think they would be in the 49
and 24 with a 2.1% multiplier depending
on on their higher date but they would
they had less than four years as of one
one of 12 so you know basically they've
been acre a multiplier and that's been
part of the the rates that of 2.1% a
year for every year work so you know
they they under the commission proposal
they acrew that multiplier for the first
10 years so that's 21% of their AFC
ultimately when they retire but
beginning on their 10th anniversary
which is in this case is 2018 you know
the multiplier is 2.5 going forward so
that's 5 years for that individual where
instead of a 2.1 multiplier which we
were funding towards it's two and a half
so it's it's like 2% more in the pension
you know type of thing and that's the
the backfilling part of the unfunded
obviously the farther back you go the
unfunded is more associated with the
folks who have more service now because
they you you're crewing it and and you
know for somebody who was hired
yesterday there isn't really any
unfunded associated with that person
it's just a going forward cost although
you know these are all Blended together
so there's no disproportionate separate
rates for different people based on you
know when they started but you know that
that's that's how it works so that 20
that 15year person they worked another
to work up to 25 years say so the 15
years um 2.1 time 15 is
31.5 I think you know that's what the
current multiplier would have generated
at two and a half that's
37.5 so you know it you know it would
increase the ultimate the percentage of
their average final compensation you
know that they retire with and that
increases the the lifetime benefit so
that that's in a nutshell
right I I I am in the middle of working
on some handouts if if I would have
rushed over here if this was going to go
out today but it gives us more time to
vet them and fine tune
them so very quickly for representative
Sweeney and grassy um as far as 436 when
the commission recommendations we're
going to hold off we're going to
expedite a bill but a separate bill to
deal with the commission's
recommendations allowing retirement the
LBA and Os to come up with good verbiage
good fiscal notes because it was just a
little rushed and um
knowing that you two are both absent
representative Maguire pushed forward an
amendment to add 50 million doll back
house bill 50 uh that we passed here and
that was passed by the division 4 to1 so
that's you will get a chance to vote on
it and yeah 10 o' and I know that both
parties have caucuses at 9:30 or
whatever so which is now so we're all
good hey
Jerry
all
right
no all right Maguire hey hey Dan I've
got a I just got this night uh this is
their draft I wanted to give you a
copy it's your first run through but I
thought you might like to look at
[Music]
yeah
that